[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben wir machen heute
dreimal Hähnchen in drei komplett
verschiedenen Geschmacksrichtungen heute
haben wir wieder die lieben Bauarbeiter
zu Gast draußen da hilft euch nicht
wundern wenn es ein bisschen lauter ist
zwischendurch aber Tontechnikerin Sarah
gibt ihr Bestes dass man das irgendwie
wie auch immer nicht ganz so schlimm
hört so ich starte jetzt direkt und
schreibe euch die ganz genauen
Mengenangaben unten in die
Videobeschreibung das ist dann immer
easy peasy zum screenshotten und
einkaufen gehen und ähm genau macht das
Video einfach nicht so lange ab nicht
das mag ich ja nicht so so für dieses
erste Rezept schneide ich meine
hähnchenbrust in kleinere Stücke also
mundgerecht so dass man nicht abbeißen
muss sondern einmal mit einem hat sein
Hähnchen essen kann und dann machen wir
eine Art Honig sind Knoblauch Marinade
ich bin kein senfan daher sage ich das
jetzt direkt würde ich nie pur essen
aber im Marinaden gibt es noch mal
einfach ein lecker Unterton sag ich mal
an einen Geschmack und das passt dann
einfach und für alle drei Rezepte
braucht ihr jetzt nicht so super
exotische Zutaten das finde ich auch
ganz cool
[Musik]
so ich habe mein Hähnchen jetzt hier
schon in einer Vorratsdose und als
nächstes nehme ich mir den Ingwer den
könnt ihr am besten mit einem Löffel
schälen weil dann schneidet ihr euch
nicht zu viel vom Ingwer weg sondern
wirklich nur die Schale dann haben wir
nicht so viel Verschwendung das werde
ich sehr fein hacken genauso wie den
Knoblauch da könntet ihr auch eine
Presse nehmen aber ich nehme so auch ja
wenn ich schon immer am Hacken und dann
packe ich auch mein Knoblauch schneide
ich hier was weg weil er die Wurzel sehr
groß ist so und dann geben wir auch
schon alles mit zum Fleisch zusammen mit
den restlichen Zutaten
[Musik]
so dazu kommen jetzt noch Olivenöl
Sojasauce Ketchup Senf
und Honig
so das ganze verrühre ich dann jetzt
ordentlich ihr könnt das jetzt wenn ihr
möchtet so 10 20 Minuten in der Marinade
ziehen lassen wenn ihr keine Zeit könnt
oder sofort verarbeiten wenn ihr viel
Zeit habt oder ihr wird sich vor der
Arbeit vorbereiten dann könnt ihr das
auch sogar Stunden vorher vorbereiten
das ist überhaupt kein Problem so ich
mache gleich den Deckel zu in der
Zwischenzeit räume ich hier ein bisschen
auf hol mir schon mal meine Pfanne und
dann können wir das ganze anbraten
[Musik]
so das Hähnchen dann wirklich nur von
allen Seiten zweieinhalb Minuten also
von beiden Seiten 200 Minuten braten
dann habt ihr insgesamt 45 Minuten
Bratzeit und das reicht vollkommen weil
wenn ihr das zu lange anbratet anbraten
auf jeden Fall wird es dann zu trocken
und äh das ist immer der Fehler den man
als Anfänger sage ich mal macht ne dass
man das einfach zu lange brennt wenn man
denkt okay es ist innen noch rot aber
ihr könnt ja auch Sicherheit mal
aufmachen weil das ist meistens gar
nicht so ich habe Reis nebenbei gekocht
ich verlinke euch mal meinen Grundrezept
unten in die Infobox und ähm ich finde
es richtig lecker aus das sieht so
glasiert aus durch den Honig vor allem
und dann reicht mir dazu eigentlich nur
noch so ein bisschen Schnittlauch
und dann sind wir fertig vielleicht noch
so ein bisschen Sesam das gibt noch mal
so einen schönen Weib finde ich weil das
so asiatisch angehaucht ist und dann ist
Gericht 1 schon fertig
[Musik]
so ich würde sagen ich gönnen wir heute
heute gar nicht mit drei Gerichte nein
gut lass auch was von Hanser übrig
genauso wie es mir vorgestellt habe ich
muss auch zugeben dass ich diese
Variante öfter gerne mal mache und es
ist sehr zart weil es eben nicht zu
lange gebraten wurde und es schmeckt
sehr würzig eine Anmerkung noch je
nachdem welche Sojasoße gekauft manche
sind auch sehr salzwand könnt ihr
Nachsetzen ich muss das jetzt in dem
Fall nicht weil meine Sojasoße schon
sehr salzig war aber wenn ihr merkt ihr
habt eine die wirklich salzarm ist jetzt
1000 verschiedene Varianten dann gerne
nachsalzen ganz am Ende aber ansonsten
lasse ich mir das jetzt schmecken und
dann geht's zum zweiten Rezept
[Musik]
so für Rezept Nummer 2 nehme ich wieder
mein Hähnchen das habe ich mir im
mundgerechte Stücke geschnitten wieder
in die Frischhaltedose und jetzt machen
wir eine joghurt-marinade das erste war
eher asiatisch also Asia Küche das
zweite ist eher so türkisch angehaucht
finde ich Orient da habe ich jetzt hier
einfach Joghurt da könnt ihr 3,5 %
liegen 1,5 %. aber ich sage 3,5 finde
ich schon optimal wenn ihr den ganz
fettigen 10 % auch in Ordnung dann habe
ich hier Paprikamark das ist noch mal
finde ich persönlich ein Tacken
intensiver als Tomatenmark einfach mit
reingeben das ganze natürliche Salzen
was darf nicht fehlen in der
orientalischen Küche natürlich Knoblauch
gebe ich auch mit dazu und ein Gewürzen
dann eigentlich nur noch Paprikapulver
Kreuzkümmel mein liebstes Gewürz aus dem
Orient und ähm Chili so ein bisschen
einfach nur für die Schärfe und dann
auch wieder alles miteinander verrühren
und da gebe ich dann auch noch ein
Schuss Olivenöl mit rein
[Musik]
und dazu passt jetzt auch natürlich
wieder Reis und ich gebe ganz zum
Schluss noch Petersilie oben drüber weil
das gibt mir wieder so ein türkischen
Flair ihr könnt diese Variante übrigens
auch im Backofen machen also diese
Marinade finde ich persönlich auch
optimal für Backofen oder dann wenn
Saison ist für den Grill
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ein Gericht was ich wirklich auch
im Sommer zum Grillen sehr sehr mag
allerdings
auch am Vortag einfach in der Marinade
ziehen lassen je länger desto leckerer
eigentlich
ich bin wirklich sehr türkisch finde ich
sehr orientalisch lecker zart zeigst du
auch oder
okay nee das ist überhaupt nicht sauer
wirklich 0,0 aber du hast recht wenn man
eine Joghurt pur ist hat man diesen
sauren ballgeschmack aber der ist
gänzlich weg geht der übertönig von den
ganzen Gewürzen vom Knoblauch etc es
schmeckt schon extrem lecker also sowas
kriegt er dann auch im türkischen
Restaurant so vom Geschmack her dann
geht's auch zum dritten Rezept
[Musik]
so ich glaube aufs dritte Rezept freuen
wir uns schon die ganze zeit also ich
habe jetzt hier erstmal ein Ei zusammen
mit Milch verquält dass wir das eine
kurze panadestraße also das ist hier
Panade halt Nummer eins jetzt kommt die
nächste Haltestation und da kommt Pankow
Paniermehl rein das ist nicht dieses
normale Paniermehl was man so kennt
Pankow ist ich würde mal sagen
asiatisches Paniermehl das gibt's
eigentlich auch in allen gut sortierten
Supermärkten das ist gar nicht mehr so
schwer zu finden so einfach rein hier in
unsere Frischhaltedose dann habe ich
hier Parmesankäse da würde ich sagen
nicht geizen ich würde schon sagen durch
die fifty 50% 50% Pankow mehr ist mehr
so und das muss jetzt noch gewürzt
werden da gebe ich jetzt Paprikapulver
rein jede süß
es hat lecker macht aber auch Farbe was
auch Farbe macht das schmeckt man jetzt
glaube ich kaum aus aber es macht halt
Farbe ist Kurkuma mich ein bisschen mit
dazu und ein bisschen Chili für die
Schärfe so Salz Pfeffer fragt ihr euch
wann kommt das zum Einsatz das geben wir
direkt auf unser Hähnchen so das
verrühre ich gleich noch ordentlich und
beim Hähnchen ist es so das war jetzt
echt durch Zufall dass ich so vom
Metzger bekommen habe das sind schon
sehr
schmale Stücke also lang aber nicht so
dick ist auch gut so weil sonst müssten
wir sie unendlich tot braten und wenn es
dick ist dauert halt länger und dann ist
die Panade schon so dunkel und so
überhaupt und innen ist noch nicht durch
daher ruhig lieber flache Stücke vom
Fleisch schneiden so jetzt salzen und
pfeffern auf beiden Seiten und dann
geben wir es einmal in die Eier Mischung
und dann in die Panade und dann mit Fett
in der Pfanne ausbraten
[Musik]
ich wollte nur sagen dass das verpasst
heute
ich habe heute zwei Sachen ohne dich
gegessen das war echt lecker tja das ist
halt so man arbeiten muss ja also
übrig gelassen aber probiert jetzt
erstmal unser Parmesan
nein
Ciao
also das ist meine Kruste aus
Parmesankäse und Pankow und ich habe
noch mit Paprika gewürzt drin Salz
Pfeffer also schon alles so Sachen die
man
auch überall ich finde es richtig geil
um ehrlich zu sein ich finde alle drei
Rezepte geil aber das ist so mein
Favorit das ist ein großes Stück Käse
direkt raus
Parmesan gewürzt
und ich muss sagen ruckizucki okay
okay
so 10 Minuten 10 Minuten und dieser
frittiervorgang nenne ich jetzt mal wenn
es richtig frittiert war auch nur von
beiden Seiten je vier fünf Minuten das
ging wirklich super schnell ja dann
würde ich mal sagen macht unbedingt die
Rezepte nach ja ehrlich speichert sie
euch weil das immer so Sachen wenn man
nicht was zum Mittagessen kochen soll
kann man auf dieses Video zurückgreifen
ja stimmt ja dann würde ich mal sagen
wir sehen uns bei meinem nächsten Video
abonniert meinen Kanal ne solche Videos
auch nicht zu verpassen tschüss
[Musik]